is it true that when you were asked to
do American Pie kicking it back to when
we were teenagers is it true that they
asked you like multiple times to do it
and what were you why why did you say no
at first and what and eventually made
you say yes well I think that I just
sort of saw it on paper and I didn't
identify with this
sort of like very very wide very normal
high school experiencing cut
all-americans oh we're going to lose our
virginity I was like honey it already
happened like yeah
it's just just do it you know
hey you know you'll figure it out later
in life and uh anyway so yeah I just
only I understood the movie but uh then
they gave me money and then I began to
understand yeah
[Applause]